he's a singer actor host
Las Vegas Legend Donny Osmond currently
performing a sellout show at Harrah's
and he probably also saw him as the
peacock on The Masked Singer and the
list goes on and on
so what's next for the iconic performer
here's what he told me
you've done everything acting hosting
multiple shows the variety show pyramid
Etc what have you not done
what have I not done probably nothing
but that doesn't mean he's ready to slow
down I don't want to retire
sounds boring to me he sold more than a
million albums worldwide and earned 33
Gold Records
I'm working on the 66th album right now
which I think will blow you away you're
going to hit that goal I'm going to hit
the goal
and the concept that I'm working on
right now no one has ever done not only
is he working on a new album but going
for a record that's my goal is to hold
the record of
the the most amount of Studio albums but
it's not all about the music to him Show
Business means Evolution you got to keep
your mind open to a lot of things I
didn't know the math singer was out
there I didn't know that the Dancing
with the Stars let alone winning it was
going to be there that's the cool thing
about Show Business you never know
what's going to happen and particularly
nowadays versus back in the olden days
when I started you have to be ready to
turn on a dime do you think you'll do
another autobiography to update I mean
it's been
15 years you know I've been asked that I
think it's inevitable I don't know yet
because the story hasn't been finished
yet I'm still creating it